other women out because that's because
it's like there's a very small
proportion of women right I think that
is right and but they're loud and their
voices are Amplified and the women that
actually is not the majority is actually
the minority that's doing that they
don't say anything and women don't like
to be called out so for what are you
saying sitting next to you
but basically she said that but when it
goes on social media not in a manuscript
just anywhere else they're going to call
her pick me a pick me up no exactly but
again like that's the same loud hurt
women that are saying you're a pick me
because you're actually talking sense
but if there's a hundred pygmies they
won't even I think if it is five year
ago I'm with you and maybe like five and
that's how mad it is so but more of them
just to stand up but but so I'll get
women in my DMs and they'll be
supporting what we're doing and they'll
be like yeah see you on Pearl show
they'll come up to me but where are they
in the comments when the girls are
trying to call them call us misogynists
and all these types of things only for
literally speaking in a way that men
haven't spoken before because men lie so
when you get men that actually you're
honest to you that's why I say women
love lies and cheaters because because
they don't want men that's actually
telling the truth because when men do
they label them all man as a thing
um they want cheaters because they
always go for the top 20 of men and the
men that have access to more women they
want polygamy relationships because not
because they will have a baby with a guy
that's already had a baby with another
woman you are sharing a man once you do
that in their mind they may think oh you
know what he's not with her no more but
if you give a man if you allow a man to
have baby with another woman then come
and have Baby View afterwards then
you're actually allowing him to have the
best of both figs you know what I mean
so yeah violent violent felons have more
children than non-violent yeah
and I said this before like and I
thought about it and I know one of my
like you know so like it was a good old
friend I don't have to speak about his
name but just he's literally what she's
talking about he would be the most red
flag you could think of but for some
reason bear girl bear like you know even
yellow blue tick moving imagine like
yeah you're supposed to have some type
of nah it's just I just I think when
they say digmatize I think it's real you
know do you think that the the quality
of women drops when it comes to these
types of guys or do you think it's still
top tier I wish I could say I think he
said my thing is a mentality thing yeah
it's just how they wired in their
Britain I wish I could say it was like
dead cat
that's why it even makes you you know
what sometimes I think
it's like if I see your baby father and
I had high high levels for you and then
I see your baby father I was like oh is
that all of a sudden it kind of drops
and you've always said that you kind of
you can't get no pretty much higher than
your baby forever so you're seeing a
stunning woman or whatever and then you
see the guy that she's given the highest
honor to and you just you was feeling a
little bit like maybe she was out of you
disappointed and then you see that
you're like oh
so I mean what what's the stereotype
stereotype stereotypes exist for a
reason right and young women are the
like the most valuable to men right in
in general throughout all of time and
young women date who Bad Boys um so at
the peak of our youth infertility we
tend to waste it on Bad Boys yeah
and but you need the bad boy thing do
you noticed that women stop going for
bad boys as they get older I do think
it's still in them no I think I think
that women
um just can't either can't get the bad
boys they used to get and so in their
head they settle
um
they're like oh I grew out of it but I
just like
um
they just fail to be honest with
themselves and say that I can't get that
guy anyway yeah or they can't get them
to commit like that's what I see more
it's like they want the bad boy but they
can't lock him down like no one can
right so it's like they can't lock him
down and so then this is it's
interesting to hear from like the men's
point of view because like to women this
is more of like new information but to
men they're like yeah we've been knew
this but do you think that men also like
bad girls do you think nice girls get
finished last as well because I always
hear guys girl lots of talk about how
women like bad guys but I see lots of
nice women being ran through as well
like just ignored or just in the back
burner while he's and it does this thing
with lots of other women it's not hard
enough yeah maybe and I wouldn't even
say that as well nice girls finish last
as well are you a really nice girl if
you're going for the bad boy that wants
the top 20 and this is that thing again
so you can as a nice girl you're a nice
girl but you're making bad decisions
yeah that's true you're still chasing
after the girl
um so the guy that which all the all the
bad girls want as well so if you're a
nice girl you put yourself in that in
that Marketplace then you just become
another one of many yeah a real nice
girl will say you know what I like him
and maybe for one night but reality for
long term no he's not gonna many girls
have to make the decision they have to
pick between yeah they wouldn't connect
and they're still in that bad guy
between the the Sure Thing versus the
you know what I mean he's gonna he's
gonna get my door kicked off by the
police guy and it's like when you made
that decision we actually judge you
differently because yes you could have
carried on looking at the sky's the
limit and that hypergamy thing but you
said no I'm gonna cut off here and this
is the thing which women can't do they
don't know when to actually say you know
but it's time for me to cash out yeah do
you know what it is as well though like
that probably means a lot of women don't
like actually know when a man's lying so
you get these good girls that will think
that they've found a good guy
he's actually a bad guy in Disguise
that's true and he's just playing that
act and right and a lot of these girls
some some girls are very naive though
some girls are very nice I think okay I
think a lot of girls don't actually
understand me enough okay okay okay that
can happen to you once you can get
bamboozled once
but what is her body count one this girl
that got bamboozled
I think if women don't have many male
friends and all their friends are girls
they tend to be more naive about what
male Behavior looks like so they're ones
that don't have many male friends they
don't really get how men move whereas if
you have a lot of men around you you
learn some of the tricks of the trait so
I do think sometimes they can be more
naive especially if they're asking other
girls
I'll give you one time but it's like
okay he did it he did it he did it he
did he did it and you're still naive
that don't make sense to me yeah like I
just like for me yeah
everyone's allowed one even two like you
know what I mean like we'll give them
tips we'll give them two we'll give them
to you the only reason I'm giving you
two is because like they've been telling
me I need to get a little bit better
with trying to like I don't know I don't
know I'm listening to people so I'm
gonna give you two just because people
say oh real life stuff happens and okay
so I want to be a real life person we'll
give you two but how many times do you
get to keep them making the same
um mistake or doing the same offense
getting arrested for it but I think I
think you're underestimating like the
level of gaming some guys have you know
what I mean like a lot of guys are like
slippers
if there's ten guys how many have game
would you say out of ten two all right
but if if it's a stereotypical bad boy
okay so let's two so she could have
picked the eight nice guys good guys and
she picks the guy with game and that's
the stereotypical bad boy I just don't
feel bad like
from what I've seen is that the guys
that are smooth talking have got game
that are players they'll have good girls
bad girls bad bees this that any other
but like the good girls fall for the
same lies the bat like the babies like
like yeah they all fall for the same
lies and they don't have a clue what's
going on they don't they're genuinely
clueless and they'll be crying to their
friends saying that I can't believe we
did this because they genuinely don't I
no I used to I used to kind of think
like you
but you're switched on though a lot I
think I think oh no it's not though like
it's not even that I'm switched on it's
just like I've just heard girl after
girl after girl come on my show and like
I got cheated on by him him and him and
it's like how many times were you
bamboozled this is it though it's like
yeah but you know what it is yeah and
it's like you must have liked something
about the toxic relationship because
you're still talking about him three
years later so it's something with you
that you're attracted to him like I just
don't buy it like one of the things that
I hate and one of the things we're
suffering with is all these women with
trauma but like we cannot remove
accountability and you're removing a
woman's accountability unless it was
great we have to say that this woman
said yes she laid down she opened her
legs and she let these bad boys come
into her and this is one of the things
that I keep saying is because if we
don't what are we saying oh man had game
and because man had bars yes man had
bars man had game but she didn't have to
fall for it so end of the day is if you
go and breathe out some girl and she's
some badena and she's like you know
she's like she's just a walking red flag
and then you start crying later No One's
Gonna feel sorry for you bro like that
literally because you didn't do your due
diligence yeah so a lot of men do this
they go and have babies with women that
they shouldn't have babies when they
start talking about my baby mother drama
I would have never even gone there in
the first place but you did for any
reason and now you've got problems the
same way with these women if you're a
good girl you know a bad boy all the
things inside your body tell you but
because he's the top 20 he's good
looking he's got whatever he's got you
want him then it goes bad because he's a
child and he does what exactly what Chad
and tyrones do and then you want to
acquire blue murder then you meet us in
your 30s and now you've got a lot of
trouble when you're talking about my
mistrust for guys none of this mistrust
came from me why am I paying for for you
deciding to get run through in your in
your 20s by some guys I hear that and
obviously them kind of women in their
30s that you got to stay clear the ones
with the Mad trauma because it's all of
them it's not it's not all of them there
are there are the thing is it's not 80
that's what we're dealing with if you
meet 10 girls eight of them are
suffering from my head I heard that yeah
that's probably true if you but that's
what I'm saying but it's not all it's
not all but if you can maneuver through
the history but if it's 80 that's still
alive
that's like every girl like me
I mean like honestly I think even
earlier than that I think by 25 most
girls about their heart broke once
I think about 25. yeah I was giving them
basically what I'm saying is right yeah
okay and another reason why women get
their heart broken early is because
they go for these bad bad boys right and
if you're in your 20s and you haven't
you know the world hasn't hit you hard
yet and a lot of times they'll date the
oh the older guys now there's good guys
all the guys which you can date and
they're not gonna ruin your heart all
these older guys that are gonna show you
about something and then once it all
starts to happen the trauma starts to
happen so all I'm saying to women is
whenever you speak to women men will lie
like initially it was supposed to be
your father your brother that was going
to vet these men that will come into
your life now with the
absence of fathers in the home and women
are having the same relationship with
their brothers there's no one really
spitting this game to them so when you
hear it from a man and you're in your
20s on your 30s it sounds like it sounds
like we're trying to stop you from doing
certain things we're just saying no like
you should have been told that I agree
if you spin this that for the way I see
it is that I just think a lot of women
don't actually understand the men enough
do you know I mean they don't actually
fully understand men so that's why they
end up falling into the same trouble as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible